it's the 108 page document from the
Privileges committee you can go first of
all just to that very damning conclusion
where they say that Boris Johnson should
be suspended for 90 days which is an
extraordinary punishment proposed by a
conservative-led committee now we've
been going through some of the bits uh
further into this document just to just
to ascertain what the arguments are what
what is it that means that those MPS
have decided to judge Boris Johnson so
harshly and we're gonna have a little
look at what they concluded on Gathering
so here we are it's got a long way into
the report
um and essentially uh they say that one
of the arguments Boris Johnson deployed
time and again uh was that it was
absolutely essential or reasonably
necessary for work purposes to have all
of those thank yous those leaving drinks
the birthday celebrations the
motivational events if you remember in
the Committee hearing Boris Johnson made
absolutely clear uh and the committee
note this uh that that is an important
part of being a boss at an organization
and therefore that's what he was doing
but here's what the committee basically
decided uh they decided that while five
of the six events uh do focus on
thanking staff for working hard or
raising uh morale but they don't believe
that that is a permitted activity under
the rules we do not believe that if
asked at this time whether unsocially
distant leaving dues to maintain staff
morale were permitted under the rules
and Gardens uh uh uh he would have been
advised uh by the he he would not have
advised the British public that they
were and so essentially what they're
doing is mounting an argument there of
hypocrisy which is one of the charges
coupled with the fact that he did it too
and his team did it to uh that the
committee have seized upon they also
talk about how there was no obvious
social distancing at any of the events
uh for which the committee have
photographs now actually we've already
seen quite a lot of the photographs and
they're they're later on in this report
uh but the committee has decided to
judge him quite harshly on the fact that
they can't see people uh maintaining
social distances we have no evidence of
substantive mitigations in places in
place in the rooms or areas where the
Gathering uh took place you remember one
of the arguments that Downing Street
tried to mount uh was that effectively
because Downing Street was such a safe
location in some points rather early on
in covert there was testing there were
other you know it's one of the few
workplaces in the country where there
was quite a lot of activity they put in
place things to protect all the staff
they say that is not in evidence in any
of the uh photographs that they look at
um and he says Mr Johnson concedes the
social distancing was not possible at
these events but maintains the guidance
was complied with completely and here it
is they're very Stark about it they say
this is not correct Mr Johnson refers to
social distancing of less than two
meters as imperfect this term is not in
the garden so what they have done this
committee is essentially to fill it the
argument made by Boris Johnson in that
committee and just highlight where they
don't think it's true that how he has
reinterpreted this is what they say
later on in the report he has
reinterpreted the guidance uh in his
favor but they don't think he's done so
fairly we think it is highly unlikely on
the balance of probabilities that Mr
Johnson in light of his cumulative
direct personal experience of this event
and his familiarity with the rules and
guidance as their most prominent public
promoter could have genuinely believed
at the time his of his statements for
house uh that the rules were being
complied with we think it is just as
unlikely he could have continued to
believe at that at this time uh we think
we think it just as unlikely he could
have continued to believe this at the
time of his evidence to our committee we
conclude that when he told the house and
hit this committee that the rules and
guidance were being comply complied with
his own knowledge was such that he
deliberately deliberately misled the
house and this committee that's at the
core of the argument it's what the
committee thought before the hearing I
have to say but here here it is he knew
he was there he knew the rules he
misinterpreted them deliberately and
they believe he lied to the house